malhabiles à tous
manila
c'est bastien et anthony organise avec
leur association l'écurie jacques-coeur
la course de côte régionale de sancerre
anthony m'attend pour m'embarquer dans
cette compétition automobile qui compte
pour la coupe de france de la montagne
et vous allez également découvrir que la
route jacques coeur qui est un
patrimoine historique et cher au centre
val de loire et vous allez également
découvrir mon cri le plus stridents de
120 km/h dans les virages eux
et moi je n'y connais vaguement bagnols
vouloir renault alpine à 1960 nature
ajoute 10 ans était dans le vrai 70 vous
bossez koala compresseur non l'ascenseur
bon ok j'y connais rien ça marche vous
bossez surpoids dégage enfin en train de
remonter le turbo quoi elle va pas déjà
assez vite la voiture c'est ça on l'a
boosté un peu plus pour faire un tour
avec toi alors vous la vouliez la boue
ça peut plus présenter - cochet de
voiture donc ça c'est une hausse koras
un prototype français qui a couru dans
les années 80 90 ça fait 800 kg pour 350
chevaux c'est l'ultra rapide et tu
sautes d'un virage à l'autre ses marques
et anthony dubois au plus ça fait partie
de notre famille ou plus ouais c'est ça
c'est le groupe sanguin à cesser si on a
une perf à faire mais rend à mettre le
tient toute attente le groupe sanguin il
marquait sur la voiture pour s'y est
franchement c'est cool ça va être super
avant que tu te lances dans la
compétition est pleinement dans
l'univers du garage je dirais tu fais
autre chose avant oui j'ai eu une autre
vie j'ai travaillé à la banque dans un
établissement bancaire pendant plus de
dix ans la passion était plus forte que
tout m'est donc le du coup j'ai décidé
de changer de voie les liens sont forts
comme avec sébastien mais bien sûr ça
fait des années qu'on se connaît nos
parents c'est des courses de voitures
ensemble déjà à l'époque donc j'ai vu
depuis tout petit du coup je vais aller
voir que l'on possède quel est ton rôle
dans l'association est ce que tu
pourrais me parler un peu de la création
l'association a été créée et est donc en
1972 par pierre champeau ça a été la
première association de sport automobile
qui a été créée dans le département
toute la france venait courir sur la
course de côte de sancerre aujourd'hui
on va organiser la 47e camp
l'association jacques coeur mais
pourquoi jacques terre alors jacques
heures c'est la figure emblématique de
bourges la devise de jacques coeur c'est
à coeur vaillant rien d'impossible
donc on pensait que ça ne collait
parfaitement toi t'es tu es le petit
jeune c'est ça de l'écurie qu'est ce que
tu fais de beaux ici ici en fin de
compte j'ai d'anthony sur tout ce qui
est mécanique et entretien de la voiture
et tu dois faire la compétition plus
tard j'ai pas bien ouais ouais mais bien
des passions la doublure nativité riquet
merci d'avancé
[Musique]
la sq au
hockey
[Musique]
voilà quelle mini tu es content
ouais ouais ouais ouais super merci
anthony merci
je vais mal à arriver tu vas où ben je
repars france 3 centre val de loire là à
tanger cinq minutes je peux déposer si
tu viens danser non merci à mes yeux
c'est un vrai plaisir oui je sais je
sais que d'autres bersim des trois ponts
de mercy j'aurai le marché regarde la
région c'est magnifique comme tu veux le
village sous la verdure ok merci anthony
allez salut merci sony